on le voyait en introduction les océans
vivent des bouleversements sans
précédent mais quel est l'impact sur les
êtres vivants qui habitent ces
écosystèmes marins à l'ère des
changements climatiques
y at il des gagnants et des perdants cap
sur le golfe du saint laurent
[Musique]
le golfe du saint laurent est une
immense mer intérieure
[Musique]
dans les villages côtiers les bateaux de
pêche des charges de leurs cales des
poissons des crustacés et désolant curie
mais si à première vue l'activité semble
prospère tout n'est pas rose au large
[Musique]
le golf subi les contrecoups des
bouleversements qui secoue les océans
partout sur la planète
au quai de rivière au renard en gaspésie
la saison de pêche à la crevette bat son
plein comme la plupart des pêcheurs on
hariot côté et son fils jean frédéric
ont dû composer avec les changements qui
affectent le golfe du saint laurent
je sais que l'on s'y réchauffer dans le
garçon a rendu quand on peut on peut
pousser à cacher que ça fait pas tout ce
que ce qu'on a atteint le schubert des
cdc c'est gros mais sais tu nous autres
la solution c'est tout de suite ça ne me
pose la question
comme les pêcheurs les scientifiques
canadiennes se pose des questions sur
l'impact de cas le réchauffement des
eaux sur les espèces marines pour le
biologiste hugo bourdages tout n'est pas
blanc ou noir dans le golfe du saint
laurent
oui en a qui vont s'en tirer moins bien
mais en écumant sentir et qui mange qui
ont bien s'en tirer par exemple le
homard se porte à merveille
par contre des espèces comme le crabe
des neiges la crevette et le turbo ont
déjà de la difficulté à s'acclimater
il n'y a pas de bon et de pas mal à se
réchauffer alors qu'on observe c'est
plus un déplacement de nos espèces dans
l'espace il ya plusieurs exemples
d'espèces qui se porte bien dans cet
environnement là qui est charles qui
échangea
c'est le cas du sébaste qui est devenu
le nouveau roi du céleri en 2011-12 et
trahi
on sait pas trop pourquoi exactement
mais on a vraiment gagné à la loterie à
savoir qu'on a trois courts important de
ses bases qui sont apparues qui vont
bientôt leur rentrée à détail
appréciable pour la pêche commerciale le
sébaste est un poisson de fond qui peut
vivre jusqu'à 75 ans comme ceux de la
morue ces stocks ont chuté de façon
dramatique dans les années 80 à tel
point qu'il a fallu imposer un moratoire
sur la pêche
mais contre toute attente des relevés
récents au chalut ont confirmé le retour
spectaculaire du sébaste dans le golfe
du saint laurent
la barrière d'après nos ethnies 90% de
la bio-masse qu'on attrape et dans le
fond du golfe représentait de ces bacs
si on compare avec le porter c'est un
poteau de caisse pour ça dans la salle
des bassins de l'institut maurice
lamontagne à mont joli
les chercheurs caroline sonné et denis
chabot explore plusieurs hypothèses pour
tenter de comprendre leur établissement
étonnant des populations de sébaste
celle qui semble la plus plausible et
qu'elle était bas font une des rares
vrais pères qui tirent plutôt bien leur
épingle du jeu face au changement
climatique
les chercheurs ont capturé 800 sébaste
dans le saint-laurent pour les exposer
ensuite aux variations de température et
d'acidité qui sont anticipés dans le
golfe d'ici la fin du siècle
le but du projet c'est de pouvoir mieux
prédire à la physiologie les besoins
énergétiques
le taux de croissance le taux de survie
du sébaste aux conditions actuelles et
aux conditions futures
une des victimes du retour en force du
sébaste et la crevette nordique après
avoir atteint des niveaux d'abondance
historique
sa population a fortement décliné depuis
2010 pas surprenant puisque le sébaste a
fait de la crevette une de ses
principales proies
une chose est certaine il y aura des
gagnants et des perdants
ici comme ailleurs et il faudra se
montrer récit lire car les changements
que nous vivons sont là pour durer
c'est clair que le golfe du saint
laurent dans 50 ans vont être différent
de celui d'aujourd'hui
donc il ya encore une biodiversité à ce
moment alors mais on enrobe perdu
l'écosystème comprenez actuellement est
à mes yeux c'est une perte pour la
planète et pour nous
ce bouleversement mondial des
écosystèmes est un enjeu de taille
l'océan est la plus grande source de
protéines de la planète
c'est le garde manger de plus de 3
milliards d'humains et ce sont les
habitants des pays en développement qui
seront les plus touchés
la raison le réchauffement de l'eau
provoque déjà le déplacement de
nombreuses espèces vers les pôles et va
laisser un vide alimentaire dans les
régions tropicales
mais selon certains scientifiques
les changements climatiques ne sont pas
la seule menace à la survie des stocks
de poissons la surpêche
c'est la raison principale de la ludo
klein de la santé des océans
parce que la surpêche et la pêche en
fait c'est fait pour tuer des poissons
à vancouver au bord du pacifique daniel
pauly dresse un constat accablant de
notre gestion des pêcheries ce chercheur
a consacré sa vie à étudier l'impact des
pêches sur les stocks de poissons dans
la plupart des pays la surpêche
c'est le résultat d'une pêche un
contrôle et donc là la pêche un contrôle
et ça devient un peu une surpêche
parmi les espèces qui sont exploités au
maximum de ce qu'elle peuvent endurer
on pense au temps et aux requins la
pêche ne produit rien la pêche ne fait
que ramasser ce que la nature produit
des poissons se palper choc les produits
il ne fait que les ramasser selon les
chiffres recueillis par l'onu 94 % des
stocks de poisson serait à la limite de
leur exploitation ou bien sûr exploiter
mais peut-être est-ce davantage le
problème c'est que trop souvent on ne
sait pas avec précision ce que les
pêcheurs sortent de l'océan finale
méconnaissance des prises réelles des
pêcheries mondiales à cacher une partie
du déclin encore aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que les stocks sont
maintenant qu'en fait qu une s'écroule
très souvent selon lui une des solutions
pour en arriver à mettre en place une
pêche durable serait d'arrêter de
maintenir en vie artificiellement
cette activité économique au détriment
de la ressource tout des frais qui a
besoin d'être d'être subventionné a
besoin d'être abandonnés parce qu' elle
ne devrait pas continuer parce que
nature nous dit laissez-moi tranquille
il faut que je me repose
il faut que je me remette et ce message
très clair que la nature nous donne
on n'a pas besoin de l'écouter quand on
aime des subventions donc voilà on
continue à pêcher malgré le fait que les
ressources soient excellent
[Musique]
partout sur la planète les pêcheurs
n'ont pas le choix ils devront continuer
à s'adapter a pris le bateau comme mon
grand père a fait aussi on va s'habituer
avec ce qui arrive il ya du monde il
serait malheureux à travers la planète
ou complète affecté là dedans ça va être
une grosse part de responsabilité à
mondiale afin juste pêcheurs c'est
mondial de favorite
[Musique]